a little bit of a big question to start
here because I've grown a little
obsessed with this idea someone shared
with me recently about the importance of
having your own personal secret a better
role before taking on a new character so
even with a great screenplay great
source material what's something
specific to you and your take on Riri
that was really important for you to
bring to screen here
um
I love that question and I've also heard
that that Viewpoint um about you know
how folks enter into their roles and I
think for me
um I don't know if it's a bit of a
secret but I think uh talking about a
disco around has definitely been the
first time I've really shared it is that
it was important for me that Riri
Williams who we all know is a super
genius and who we all know does this
incredible build
um by making her Iron Heart suit it was
important for me that she was outside of
what folks might expect when they think
about what a genius looks like or what
someone who goes to MIT sounds like
um or or just how they carry themselves
in that space and so I wanted to to see
um which thankfully was a choice and a
hope supported by uh the words but that
Ryan coogler and Joe Robert Cole had
down on paper and also of course the
character that ebuing had established
um so I'm very glad that I had I was
given a character that could support
that hope of mine but also in me
figuring out how I embody Riri is
wanting to figure out how I could play
around in different moments and maybe do
something differently than whatever my
first thought might be she her energy
was infectious and it felt very specific
to you to me and that's always all I
ever want from from any role for that
matter I wanted to look ahead a little
bit to uh the Iron Heart series given
what she goes through and what you go
through in this movie actually I'll
start there first for you as an actor is
there anything that you saw another
wakanda forever actor do on the set of
this film that made you stop and say
like when I'm number one on the call
sheet I want to be able to do that for
my set hmm
um I think
um this sort of advocacy for their
character
um that I got to see folks do on wakanda
forever just in the rehearsals in the
conversation and the discussion question
about what someone might say how they
might react how they might respond
um it was um uh definitely a bit of a
master class I think being in some of
those rehearsal rooms
um and also a great uh gift that that uh
the directors I've worked with
fortunately have offered by being open
to hearing like what
our input could be on a character as
they trust that we as the actors are are
showing up to do our job and to take the
time to to know these characters uh
quite well
um so definitely when I when I got over
to ironheart I it was reinforced in me
that I am rere's number one Advocate and
to make sure that no matter what the
circumstance no matter what change in
the day scripts and anything going on
that um that rui had a representative at
all times
um yeah I love that all right so now for
for Riri specifically as a character
because wakanda forever really well
highlights how everyone is influenced by
those around them and how everybody
winds up living on through each other so
based on what she experiences in wakanda
Forever is there any particular thing in
terms of how Riri was shaped during this
film that we're gonna see you kind of
dig into a little more in the ironheart
series series I think
um I think that uh one of the beautiful
things about ruri is that when we meet
her both in the comics and uh on screen
we're meeting someone in the middle of
their day-to-day we're sort of getting
to peek in at someone's life in the
middle of it uh we haven't really gotten
the origin story that we might expect
when we hear that a new hero is being
introduced
um but rather it feels more like a day
in the life of this 19 year old college
student who also happened to do
something crazy in her spare time and
now she kind of has to deal with it
um and so I think that when we get to
dive into her world in ironheart we're
also getting the opportunity to explore
who Riri is when the stakes are not
quite as exaggerated
um but also to see what Adventures she
might get into when
um when or if she does have to she does
have to sort of reflect depend on on
content with the the Ambitions of hers
that got her into that situation in the
first place you know I don't think it's
until this moment and will come to
Forever when we think about why now like
why on this day are we seeing Riri well
on this day she realizes
the potential that her Brilliance has I
was already excited for the series your
energy in this movie is infectious
though and now it is easily one of my
most anticipated of the many MCU
properties on the way so huge huge
congratulations to you thank you so so
much I'm so so happy to hear that